Mình đến sáng 1, 1 lũ tại các tình mình bắt đã gây thiệt hạnh nghiệm trong
có hơn 8,5 người khác tà lúa và hoa mầu biện ngập ủng
hơn 18,5 gần ra súc và sấu trăm chiến miên nghiệm còn sắp cần bị chết quần trôi
hơn 28,5 gần kinh à bị ngập
trong đó, diệu tháng 1,7 gần, chiến hơn 2,7 gần nha
tổng thiệt hại ước tính, bởi vì nguyện không chăm 5,5 gần
trong đó tháng 1,7 gần, chiều thiệt hạnh nạn nhất khoảng 1,5 gần đi động
đặt thử đẹp mắt kê một ờ lạng sơ bị vợ sâu lưu lượng lũ lưỡ lớn
chính quyền địa puyên đã kịt thời sơ tán hơn 8,5 gần đến nơi ăn toàn trước khi sảy rả sự cố
còn vùng đã khi nhận 5,5 gần nha sử cố đi điều tập chúng chủ yếu ở bắt nình tháng 1 và hà nội
nhiều tuyên đe như tà hiệu cầu, hữu thân cà lộ, phải tổ chức chống tràn khẩn cấp với tổng trường dài
gần 2,5 gần, sau thông cũng bị an hưởng nghiêm trọng với hơn 2,5 gỳ quốc lộ sắp lợ
nực nớt, kuyến đường sát hà nội đồng đăng tạm dừng trải cầu, ngang định lực kinh nhận hơn
5,5 gần mới chính nghiên khai khẳng mất điện, dạ khuy phục cho hơn 4,5 gần
còn hơn 1,5 gần nha sử cố điện, nãng lộ gài lũ trên sông cầu xung thường vẫn ở trên mức báo được bà
nguy cơ ngập lột sật lợ để điều và lụ quát có thể tiếp tục sây ra trong những ngày tối
kể để phương được yêu cầu không chủ quan, tăng cường tổng trà kinh gắt nè, sản sàng lực lợng và tư hướng phó theo phương trầm bốn tại trộ đề bảo đam ăn toàn trong người dân